[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
hey guys I'm Jesse and I'm here for a
tech and seven stream joined by Richard
our producer we've got mark from the
tech and 17 he's a brand manager and we
have a pro player in the house today mr.
naps very excited we're gonna be playing
Tekken 7 the arcade version but the
version that's coming out for consoles
is a newer version right yes definitely
there's a lot more new stuff obviously
there's a lot more characters and also a
story mode so look at the Clemson ball
has been arcades but the console release
hasn't way more content in it awesome
and also we're gonna be hanging out in
the chat so if you've got any questions
for us or for our pro please ask on our
twitch or our youtube channels first
we're gonna have mister naps warm up and
tell you a little bit about him
we're gonna roll that clip right now
he's got a really cool
he's trying to figure out how to walk up
the stairs or another day there we go we
were holding it yeah there he is
so Knapp's has been out to international
events enjoy em from Bannon fo six times
now this is a sixth trip being sponsored
to Japan Nene he's putting ads up for
the confidence not impressed by the Lili
cosplay uh-huh yes mr. knab's is our pro
player today and he is the king of the
Iron Fist North America champion is that
right correct what is geeft best in the
USA he's been a longtime Tekken player
and he's also from San Jose to you so
even more special he's from the Bay Area
Bay Area native nice all right so we're
gonna ask him some questions while he's
warming up he's gonna get to warm up
right now so mister naps tell us about
your background so I was born and raised
in San Jose and I've been playing Tekken
for about 12 years now
competitively and um that's all I got
how did you get into Tekken so I went to
the arcades uh I went to arcades really
often and one day there was Tekken 5
second five just come out and I noticed
the customizations were really cool so I
wanted to get a card and get like
character customized and look really
cool and that's how I got into Tekken
very nice another question who is your
least favorite Tekken character ever
that's really difficult that's really
difficult just because I like a lot of
character this game how about least
favorite character to play against least
favorite
it's probably the Meucci most me schmoes
you have to worry about you have to
worry about running into things a lot
yeah that's pretty it's pretty difficult
you have to think about it like pretty
much the entire match it's like really
stressful so I think niche modes will be
the one I disliked elite or the most I
should say got it and also what is your
number one what do you think is the
number one biggest mistake people play
when they're playing second what do they
make I think the number one biggest
mistake would be that people try to
generalize things a lot and then they
get overwhelmed because there's so much
about this game but they should really
learn to take it little by little and
learn everything slowly because this
game is all about
like a small progress rather than big
progress right away so people should
really keep that in mind when learning
about this game nice and how is the
competitive scene in Tekken 7 this year
this year it's a little hard to say for
especially for North America because we
don't have the game quite yet but it's
looking quite good with the the tour
events going on and also everyone's
really excited so one more week awesome
all right so he's warming up but we are
going to jump into mr. knab's vs
GameSpot we're all gonna get wiped Ringo
yeah we're gonna wreck so we have a lot
of brave souls here today they're going
to take on mr. Knapp so we're gonna see
who can get one round in on mr. yes what
do you think do you think our chances
are slim I would say slim to impossible
oh boy I think I got one round off Jimmy
at one point in the office I think I
remember that you remember that too a
distraction least favorite song what do
we have exactly you know actually the
office what I do is I play Britney
Spears maybe some christiana Galera just
to throw people off that would hike me I
don't know what get ready to play it
ever floats your boat um but uh I would
say the psychological games here are at
play so second mouth say some weird
stuff and you might knock to me off this
game got it alright what I was in for an
environment turn that's true he's in our
house now so let's see so who do we have
first Richard we have mr. wen hua
engineer extraordinaire mr. Wynn is here
to play against mr. naps and the goal is
to try to take one round for mr. Nash
one round one single round and we'll
take some questions from the chat while
you guys are playing so let's see what's
going on on YouTube and twitch right now
a lot of people are excited they're
saying there's one week out yep very
excited I want to try the PC version to
someone on YouTube what's the tickle him
I thought it was very strategic stand on
the other side of to move and while
we're playing up again sirs having been
I think it's a really good idea all
right who do we have
so we got Shaheen come up around the
stream yes new to Tekken 7 one of the
cool things about Tekken is a lot of the
fighters are from real world places so
he is actually in Saudi Arabia so you
know with the new roster we also have a
character from the Philippines this time
around you know we realized that there's
a lot of you know fans across the globe
so this is kind of an odd in a kind of
thing to leave you stuck that's awesome
how do they do it let's see we got here
we got Brian this is amis Misha hair
turn cameo has been amazing yes Jimmy's
been using Spectre for I believe 12
years now so it is not going easy right
now we're gonna get come on 10 you can
get one round mr. Winn so looking at
gameplay the people out there on the
stream right now the last release we had
was second tag - that was a tag game so
it was a lot more complicated because
you actually had to play with two
characters so here it goes back to its
original 1vs1 format it's a lot easier
to pick up and play got it um there's
also a lot and a lot of new features in
the game which is alright there's
something we can experiment Kanaks will
start with rage art yes
so the rach art so if you look at
shakira now he's going red so when
you're in low on health you are dropped
into this rage mode but in that mode you
actually do more damage
so what also happens is you have access
to a range art and also a rage drive and
those are special moves basically super
a better way to Scooby Shiva
um so it allows like an easy comeback
mechanic into the game so if we're down
by a lot this could shift the whole
match in to your to your favorites yeah
definitely crew seen a lotta different
final games and now it's in Tekken 7 and
it's a lot lot easier to play nice it's
a safe asset who's up next next up we
have our Twitter guru Chiba is up good
luck who you picking is Shiva could you
pick Nina Williams in the nose in the
bridesmaid outfit the bride house Oh
drugs that's right
inna and her bridal outfit so this is a
new outfit for Tekken 7
I love Nina she's a classic mm-hmm who's
she marrying that's a secret laughs that
is a top secret you will find out on
June 2nd I know everything but don't try
to unlock my chamber so you'll find out
when you get the game guys all right mr.
naps versus Shiva let's see let's go
Nina there's no gays Mario inna go nice
girl break oh here we go you're all that
cool thing about taking able to see in
other games is the stage [ __ ]
transition so as a little break um so
they transition to a whole new father's
day it's very cool so not all stages are
like that but it adds a lot of variation
to the gameplay that's very cool so how
do you initiate those stages changes you
basically have to throw them against one
of the balconies in the stage and
actually breaks through so some of the
attacks actually any shape adds yeah
you're seeing Jimmy J North American
champ in full action right now showing
no mercy whatsoever no mercy so ever
twitch it hides the final second step
again oh you're watching the arcade
version you'll be getting the updated
version when you buy it next week yes
for Xbox one ps4 or PC round three
shaper you can do it someone tickle mr.
knab's tickle tang is allowed I would
suggest it tell someone really bad joke
[Laughter]
Oh Jimmy what's your favorite nice beer
song toxic oh that's a really good one I
learnt using maybe about you today this
is interesting
oh man all right who's up next we have
mr. Gingka
missing the saves mr. Benjamin like our
mariokart champion is here to take on
the pro will he avenge us is he the hero
we need I got some monkey Reggie got
played Nina look I'm sorry you're stuck
with Nina sorry about that
maybe look up should we give him another
round should we give him a round with
his character after this sure all right
we're gonna be nice we're gonna be nice
and give him around with his character
but first he's gonna have plays Nina
you got some tips for Nina if you have
any tips for us tell us in the chat over
on YouTube and twitch good luck then
let's see alright
nice Ben throw a brand around get around
we're up against the wall okay yes it
damage there did some damage not bad
what do you think that target Ben you
know what you guys are putting up a
valiant effort I believe in you guys
what you can see Jimmy doing here
especially in Tekken cuz it's a 3d game
is you really see him sidestepping and
making use of that 3d space so at a very
very high level better play that's what
a lot of players do so go where's the
key guys use that 3d space Oh use your
knife you have a grenade in there too
use your heels that's your best weapon
you guys you gotta use the gun down onto
your leg those four inch stilettos nice
low block here we go let's get some
action going here oh oh
someone units in someone needs to juggle
yeah but that wasn't your character Ben
alright Ben pick your character Vita
then gets a second chance
that was just sandbag yeah I just want
to show his true power yet oh yeah
they're at level 9 dollar power let's go
right then this is this time it's for
real this oh all right so Ben was
sweeping the floor with me and Matt
yesterday woman's new character so I
think both characters were Said's
yes they do wear shades Ben oh so maybe
this is a like cosplay yes Ben's got go
Ben's doing a light cosplay I can under
bed
what is Katerina Spidey tail no she is
room reminiscent of rain she does have a
lot of kicks
um I'll top my head I don't know her
actual real life what is it
tsubame bossbot Jimmy Tran knows more
than I do
there we go he lives it he breathes it
she is a Brazilian character yes we
practice the art of savate here we goes
the floor which is oh boy
use your legs legs legs legs don't be
afraid to sweep the leg there's one more
level in here so you can actually break
through one more time which news is it
French savate all right here we go
let's get you we go here we go nice
counter hit into the juggle Jimmy never
drops combos really we're going to the
wall downstairs
oh my gosh
there is blue fire watch out for the
play whoa your major crack okay
what's the rush one more I think you
need to start singing toxic right now
yeah that's the key right now I think
the crowd back there needs to start
singing
uh-huh I didn't practice my voice yet oh
here we go
Rach are coming out no mercy
ding oh there was a bit of a debate in
chat just now they said is she French
her Brazilian I think she's Brazilian
yes from Brazil right okay all right who
sucks Texas yeah let's get Espinel Iain
mr. Espinoza is your Matt Espanola is
here here we go so all right Matt you're
gonna pick let's see Brian all right our
first mirror match mr. knab's versus mr.
Espen le let's see mr. Gianelli I hope
you downloaded mr. Nath videos to watch
[Laughter]
Jimmy how you doing over there
good breaking a sweat over there just
fine
yeah well website there you go true go
to checking comm check it out check out
second comm for those tutorial videos if
you need to learn bit before you get the
game
oh nice counter hit into a launcher
we're probably gonna go downstairs here
brought us.you
Oh Matt are you the green one which ones
would know I know he's okay
hey it wasn't a perfect exactly we
should change this tuple can get around
to cooking get hat that's it
who can get the half of damage in one
wrap here we go let's do that yeah I
have faith in Joey
he'll be up next Joey's nervous Joey's
Jewish shaking his head sorry mr. Yi mr.
Yu shaking his head there we go hooray
tribes coming out yeah and with the
launch so on YouTube said checking
sevens not even know that's correct it
will be out worldwide June 2nd so watch
out for that we are playing the arcade
version right now it is like he knows
how to play Brian mr. Natz is way too
good they said on twitch someone
suggested Jimmy play with one hand oh I
think we could get a blindfold maybe
just but I might be good just buddy just
go out the app all right Joey
mr. he is up all right team game spot so
one thing cool about tech agenda is
obviously Akuma's in the game so if
you're a street fighter fan yeah you
know how to play him in Street Fighter
a lot of his move to actually are
transitioning into 3d space so all the
shelter shall move during the game so
you shoot Fighter fans out there if you
know to play Akuma you can play the
Tekken 7 haha I'm sorry yeah yeah he
gives me a lot of trouble too
it's weird fighting Akuma yes all right
this is the reason why is because Akuma
is based on a different system yes he
does a lot he has a lot of aerial
attacks and that's something hard to
deal with in Tekken because in Tekken
there's not really a lot of jumping so
it adds a whole new kind of dynamic into
the gameplay
yeah messing with messes with your
points
mm-hmm and just and just the ability to
look like Joey's looking left it Joey's
looking for hoops someone did ask for
Lily in the chances setting I like go
let's go Joey
sidestep using that space you use that
space monster balcony over there play
carefully so far good defense yes Pat
with the counter just press some buttons
there you go
[Music]
[Music]
so that if he thought home Jimmy is the
North American champion he represented
the US and the world finals last year he
is the cream of the crop so the creme
don't be scared I guess you could say I
think it's okay to be scared but don't
be disappointed in yourself yes is the
king he's got a lot of experience nice
Dodge oh here we go
I'll get that wall break yes going
downstairs
oh I'll be too yellow yeah look nice mix
up oh yeah someone just asked about that
I'll chat it said to ask what mr. Nobbs
thinks of a technical tour oh that's the
practice combo yeah oh yeah I think it's
a great opportunity for the rest of the
world to compete in the game yeah all
right so if you wipe this out it's time
for some training we're gonna get
trained by mr. naps and some of the
Tekken 7 team so we're gonna have two
game spotters fight each other first who
are we having we're having been hmm mr.
shades himself mr. shades versus mmm
we're gonna have Joey all right Joey's
dead hey Joey
all right we're gonna and we're gonna
get transferred would you like would you
guys like to help train these boys yeah
sure
all right so you can either stay here or
stand right clean them yeah I can say
yeah give her some tips okay so who is
coaching been so tom is Dalton yeah mr.
Naskh
will coach Ben and Mark you want to give
some tips to Joey definitely all right
let's see the character selection here
OOP go into there you go there you go
so I'm guessing is Brian versus uh
katarina right so mr. Epps what do you
think of some of the new characters in
this uh some of the new characters are
actually really interesting uh most of
them are pretty easy to pick up too so
they did a really good job with that so
when you advise for new players for new
players
I would advise uh katarina and also
Claudio they're both relatively easy to
pick up very nice
Oh someone picked the come up come on
so take the kuma alright alright so Joe
is gonna show up some of that Street
Fighter
all right Joe you're my guy I got you
you know how to use Akuma quarter
circles yeah I can just tell me like
jumping this week
mm-hmm all your shoot fighters these
Mambo's bring him out Joe is this your
first time using a cool boy in Tekken
yes actually I played it was pink over
it okay lets you play Manchu spider for
and what did 500k same stuff here you
even have the raging demon at your
disposal to so if you want to throw it
out there um he also has e^x moves so
you know is there the exp of there too
so if you use to punch buttons you can
pull those e^x moves off x SRK is Yolo
here we go alright nice fireball okay go
for some low sweeps here who was down a
little bit right now
just uh keep doing upward and right kick
just keep doing it Joey just gets it low
sweep slow for that's not there you go
jump in that's my plug there you go
those the bun right dragon punch DP yeah
we also had the hurricane the top -
hurricane kick in there in your arsenal
and then there you go you can link that
to a dragon punch right after together
superfood so so they can't like jump
around any future
Sarika almost all right just low sweets
cheese them that's all I get it you yeah
just give me that you don't even need
the comma rocker just that's why yeah
you do otherwise dude yeah yeah roof ah
it's like hurry for this pretty better
brother
there you go just keep doing that but I
think I will root for Ben because
nothing to play brought of shades ends
gloves and his band day yeah he's here
for them I'm just prefer jelly because
Ben beat me so many times yesterday so
this is revenge very nice good job Joey
all right Joey bringing it back around
here we go this is a pretty even match
we decided yeah let's down the chat oil
twin destruction Ryan press 1 for a boom
Oh crystal Renay oh nice yes fireball so
Ben once yes yep Ben one all right Ben
is the Randy champ oh yes
Richard Oh Richard is getting up from
the hosts see to sit down and take on
Ben so Richard uh producer
extraordinaire
I've been practicing last night yeah
yeah Richard did not sleep last night
separation for this all my life I places
Richard are you choosing Akuma Akuma
all right it's another gonna match how
do you feel about playing as Goomer
players are not competitive you know
what with Akuma I know it's a really
unpopular opinion but I really enjoy
watching Akuma I really enjoyed playing
kuma I really enjoyed playing against
Akuma so I think it's a great addition
yeah someone sings Britney Spears that's
that's my theme song which song what's
your favorite Britney Spears song I do
like toxic yeah very popular very it is
the jam know what yet you lucky and I
feel lucky right I kid you are lucky I
could you guys not this is one of the
interview questions I ask people that
apply at Bondi like what's your favorite
nice pure salt
judge them based I do actually
you're going down values sometimes
that's my brave any shirt yeah I love
some of them
alright all right let's see if Ben will
remain the champ or oh here we go
fireworks have started so the thing
about Richard he plays a lot of street
fighters Oh watch out Oh hopital kicks
just give it up
can he do all 3d space here we go slide
so you see it pulls full aerial attack
on display all righty
any tips for Richard think is doing ok
Richard's doing fine he knows BTX
DP all right the way fireballs and some
tips that yes alright sometimes you got
to pick between block or a ward right
kick nice little process you into the DP
Oh wake up DP what's erectus Richard Lee
it's two rounds here we go I think
Richards gonna take him out he's
definitely taking it out on our hate
Kevin right now hard [ __ ] press my
yeah here
all right against the wall in the rear
okay
nice Tatsu to exd yeah here we go
the trains come in victim a train
pushing to the wall easy to get splashed
pool
yeah we got some trash talking here we
got Brian enrage mode if he knows this
rate rise mark is this weight like a
time to do down a huge ambien has been
crowned GameSpot it's Richard Lee who's
taking on Richards axis - dude GG where
thanks to Geneva jump in alright Shiva
is going to take on Richard obody you
Siva oh my goodness oh there's a
fighting word out I'm just yelling sock
smack Shiva that's not an arena Shiva
pick any character you like pick any
character you like who do you suggest
could you suggest all my tag
I would suggest Katerina all right
Matthew buddies I'd really good with her
yeah you want try Katerina
okay yeah all right looks like the
opposite direction the only yeah you
tips hurt ah show you tips yeah let's
see yeah you can uh you can also pick up
ward right kick and can you keep doing
that yeah good good launcher yeah well
yeah
I'll pour dry kick yeah and twitch
something go Shiva go play extra styling
makeup goes all right little Z let's see
this is my new technique
Akuma vs UV you what you needed
I think Xiao Yu okay it looks a lot
cuter this time yeah yeah crap it's
pretty awesome yeah I like her outfits
this time a 1200 crap also the service
station T's got that yeah it's given
that all right
mmm silent this is really hard so so
you're not sticking to the plan of
upward right kick hey I know I know it's
a really boring plan if you want to win
here we go get the wrong buddy so it's
the button below that yeah up cord right
you got this you got it
hey don't do that - that's pretty good
oh that was close though look that was a
very close match
nicely done guys how about says no oh
are you kind of can can don't like a
kind of cam so if I do like the this
disorder he'll only certain moves that's
not one of the major is cheating because
he's hate playing with a I don't think
so can he play with okay Oh
ah nicely done
here we go no mercy oh wow we got
genuine rage here we go do would wake up
breakfast just do it do it I think
there's some collusion all right like
none of this oh nice lower Harry I don't
think that was important scope but it
looks really clear down forward down
four done alone
just after
Wow okay counters on counters so that's
a new change in Tekken 7 you could press
any punch button to break a normal
throws yeah makes it much easier for
beginners have you noticed any other
changes sure there are many other
changes like for example holding back to
rollback it's not owned nearly as
dangerous as it used to be yeah so
that's that's a good ol default for when
you're not go so what is the biggest
single piece of advice that you give
someone starting out playing tech toy
starting out playing Tekken I think like
I said earlier the biggest piece advice
would be to take it slowly and not get
frustrated that you don't learn
everything right away yeah because this
is games all about baby steps and
learning learning small things here and
there all the time all right still the
chance that's okay
Richard is still the champ all right
let's bring mr. Nguyen right back in
there oh he did a good job Shiva
kick ball Phoenix sister where that's
been all day
who's it gonna be I am Austin oh yeah I
think I should do better mr. Bob
I don't think so you're doing fine right
now you got a free win streak going on
right now just keep it up you know I'm
just like Steve crow over here just
watching you play thanks for the
bulletin yes we hate that so I'm gonna
play Oscar just keep doing upward and
left it all right and left it there we
go what still I'll score left it it's uh
you'll find out I'm gonna get you in the
face right now just stay at a distance
and use fireballs good yeah what's he be
in adjust to that first okay mr. one
can't spam them so do you guys prefer
playing on stick or controller I prefer
playing on stick just because that's why
I've grown up with um but everyone has
their own preferences people like to
talk about which one's better than the
other I don't think it's really a matter
of that I think it's a matter of what
your puppet or so on anything else
I'm the same way too I grew up in our
cave as boss so it just feels more
natural playing a fighting game instead
oh that's low Perry yes I think this is
an even match you want to get in there
okay good defense we see here nice
little sidestep yeah fancy nice Blake
teepee
there you go get an aerial nice combo
it's link okay
oh nice defense here we go it's dashing
romancey now all right very impressed
with Richard the practice so you're not
sticking to the plan of up or Lefty if
someone was here all day so it's
actually cool to see you know
projectiles in Tekken 7 yo obviously
Akuma's coming from Street Fighter but
as you can see here it's just easy as a
sidestep you know so not as dangerous in
Tekken but it simply cool to see yeah
yeah that's true reminder we're also in
chat on twitch and YouTube to give any
questions for any of us here the Tekken
7 team our pro or us as we suffer a
beat-down on supply under wheeler
let us know Oh Oh nicely done kick them
in the face
I wasn't way too scared whoo good job
it's your win oh you could definitely
keep doing down board kicks there we go
mark what's the best rage art you've
seen hey I like dragon offs ray charge
yes it's pretty animated and it's pretty
scary actually
oh it's like me when I you scary dude in
general yeah it's like me playing like
Reza you've a little kid I didn't want
pay that loan in the dark
game I had the lights on and I had to
have some exactly that's how I feel like
when I see dragon ops rage art and it
scared I was away from the screen
yeah I do want those things right just
call for the ground and go but I what
about yours Jimmy I think uh again
aesthetically I think I like Yoshimitsu
Wow I like ocean Explorer and
so dragon offs of course
I like okay I can see Kings rage art yet
like anything with like a like unique
moves like yeah not not just like four
or five moves pasted together with a
close-up Chuck I'm not the kind of those
poacher well this is very close for you
Richard was very good fancy nice alright
damn not dead so this is why you want to
make fun book kicks oh my goodness
so that slo-moes need a second summons
well like you can tell I like to slow
him a lot
I think it's cool for the players and
also the people like watching at home
too
you don't want some streaming or
tournaments and stuff like that you
think both upset attention I think it's
the most well-received thing about
second so yeah if you Stovall by far
most well-received Louisville I think um
what makes Tekken 7 so special this time
around is there's a lot of you in all
moments second seven right you have the
rage art you have that epic slow-mo so
it's definitely a good kind of spectator
game though Wow how did you lose all
right maddis Vannelli you're up you know
what my coach gave up no one's perfect
first day you were doing fine you didn't
need good I felt like you were doing so
well you needed to learn how to lose yes
you were doing too well
yeah he just gave up on coaching you
yeah you've got this yeah you know Thank
You mr. Kerr yeah yeah good job all
right Matt Espen le who are you choosing
Shiksha all right all right new
character Keen up forward for let's go
with that all right boy you could do
Ford and then right punch and then right
kick right kick did see that line that's
true I wear a stupid you got you guys
gave me like you guys are like steering
away from the plan getting bored plan
but you played I want to win his rage
art is the to punch buttons yeah
internalize that you got this
tattoo it on your phone and this is
clock stage has no walls you're good all
right for the GameSpot championship
that's not exactly a tree oh yeah yeah I
just give me that also block though so
pick between block all right pretty good
listen to her today yeah this is a very
even match whoo there's just hundreds
good on a chat right now someone made a
comment saying glad Richard it's only
because you were winning so much they're
rooting for the underdog but now he's a
champ so he's no longer another dog say
that I was impressed how much practice
time to Jack you did say well I was
impressed how much practice time Oh
good fundamentals in the 4-hour four
hours nice
most of it was losing to mr. Winn ah how
are you guys playing
so you met your arch nemesis yeah so we
might be close to crowning a champion
here after this what should we do we do
two more matches with this maps I think
mr. announcer play one-handed hopeful
one let me try that yeah all right let
me let me think about what's a good
one-handed carry yeah we'll have mr.
Neff play one-handed like someone
requested as a chat earlier let us know
what you want to see in the chat on
YouTube and twitch and we'll try to make
that happen for you rage are coming out
oh no blocky ooh still alive now we got
Oscar and rage oh here we go
yes okay all right the game spot champ
is mr. Wynn who doesn't even work
against upstairs and you've wiped out
the entire office how dare you sir you
walk into our house and you beat us all
up how dare you sir all right we're
gonna have mr. naps go back on and play
one-handed against who would like to
play Joey you want to play again sir all
right I should coach Joey Joey kuma yeah
let's do better father around to rest
and then he can take on the champion
how many never okay Oscar yes Oscar
what's the story behind that the story
is that they are a part of the same
organization
the previous Raven and Master Raven so
they are working towards a mission and
that will unfold in Tekken 7 what you
guys place or not all right we'll find
out more when you get the game game
comes out in June 2nd for one Jody's
going to try to get revenge
as mr. naps hanging out with playing
one-handed alright are you use gonna go
stick and buttons or just one hand in
general slanted yeah okay left hand on
sick and ones okay alright I think I
might be very impressive see you miss
got it this is probably I'll start I'll
start with Oscar Nausicaa one-handed
here we go the big disremember he can't
block as well cuz he's pressing buttons
no but that's like what I love him he's
gonna be very patient here 50 pence okay
we got a picture a picture of mr. knab's
playing with one hand
I'm impressed make sure he's actually
doing it I can't see him from here oh
here we go
yeah he can't - up there without one
hand you see it
yes we can see it now thank you
he's have to be able to finish his
combos but he's gonna get some good
momentum doing alright if he go here we
go
can't dashboard yeah
I'm very 5 seconds left
alright back to the ball it's a lot more
even now it is it is more even but I'm
still really impressed Wow spoken from
Utah bow down so for all of you just
tuning in we have pro player mr. nafs
playing one-handed against GameSpot and
still beating us you got questions from
mr. knab's let us know each event which
will relay those
Wow sweeping the floor all right Joey
Joey you got this get around Joey
question-is mokujin in this market
changes not in Tekken 7 he is on on the
roster got it is a mr. Natz fillet it's
a Bronson Tran no I'm not
that was a question which whose Bronson
I don't know any that is personally no
Bronson's actually another hometown San
Jose guy old-school Tekken player
actually went to high school with
appears so oh yeah pretty intense y'all
got the foot for Bronson can we play it
oh do you want to sure Bronson is the
voice of the West Coast we're gonna
bring it take a minute to pause and play
this Bronson clip Chama second role the
Bronson clip and then after the
Bronson's that we're gonna have another
match I think he's gonna get off
scot-free you beat his ass why you up
there
you do good who feels like worth it what
exactly it's the voice of God it's
definitely not your cooler black
conscience telling you what to do and
how this is gonna play out
not only are we gonna beat Bronson I'm
gonna take the girl that's how it works
you don't understand me but you're gonna
need it vodka poco do not let this man
get away I will talk to a for poco
that's what I'm gonna do
well I don't know if anyone told Punk oh
but Kapoor is no longer good in this
game yeah pizzazz he think he's gonna
get off scot-free right who is playing
next Ben get back in there Benjamin
djenka get back in there alright mr.
Nash is going to continue to play
one-handed and let's see if Ben can
defend himself
we believe in you
down back to get some distance in there
does anyone know how to make Jack seven
fly goal right now so sorry gonna close
up honey close up we believe you can fly
we believe you can touch the sky oh yeah
just too much compost get some distance
don't know I'm too close
you can't move efficiently right now
there you go well painful here we go
ah that's actually good for a pretty
good well you figure out how to fly so
there's that try some some grab since he
is with one hand right now I've got my
left hand the breaker grab really far as
he is moving forward try grabs I'll have
to jump back to the buttons to view
something there you go again do it again
you got this blue let's see if you can
do a rage art right now good try good
try
alright bye I think chasity was lovely
I'd like to get beat but it has one
handed don't join the club what
character you gonna use for you to go
for I'm sticking either a mirror Metro
Canada for fun and uh let's see I play
an arpeggio a mere match mere match
you're a mere match wish me luck mr.
Nath's is at a handicap right now so his
movement is gonna be a little blade less
efficient so let's try to use that 3d
space no no that's my pick my level
movement is important any more tips
setting with Hot Tips anyone gonna sing
for experience tractive um that I gotta
help me you got a dad oh yes sometimes
and I've got soothing voice yeah Beth
can you sing better so for the people
face me with your least favorite music
least favorite music yeah which I sing a
distracted a pre open mind I like all
kinds of music what is the most annoying
song to you in the whole world about
that yeah what is it
I can't think of it right now for the
most annoying sound yeah ah okay how
about caught my joke because that song
annoys the hell out of man yes yes I
broke yeah let's go for some grabs as
soon as he starts move in go for some
grabs yeah I'm free throws as
efficiently tooth there you go oh yeah
that's gonna fit again on his heels
ooh nice a beta version I know chasity
here we go who's confused I'm in blue
okay I take it as a compliment that you
didn't know
Oh nice low oops
ooh there we go now we're talking
nice power crush oh you got that's okay
okay still in this this counter
so tense in here it is it's too tense
please someone talk I'm sweating right
now I'm slacking that's actually one
thing that's very hard about Tekken is
playing and speaking at the same time
like it's two different disciplines it
is oh my god playing and singing I've
been a bit doable it is I do it all the
time action button oh he's a god I think
missing out is he is a part of Cobra Kai
no mercy
it doesn't matter he's going you guys
sweep the leg wait to the wall alright
nice throw whooping oh whoa rays are
coming out he's in the air lock
oh oh yeah oh textbook throw break oh
all right I got around hi all right uh
who's gonna fence me see believe me my
GPU back into my GPU back-end
I think this is harder than blindfolded
actually yeah I think so yes I think
this is enough of a handy counselor guys
I got around thank you one having oh
that would be difficult we could try
that blindfolded end one-handed is about
for hooding cover your eyes Jimmy all
right I'm good for the day I think I'm
gonna call it after this
perhaps if you take off your glasses
originally been Jimmy Oh how's your head
your vision with that glass
yeah tell me you let me do it Jimmy is
glasses are off the glasses are all
right new handicap the glasses are off
and he's playing one handed and the
Shiva is trying to avenge me come on
Shiva
you gotta see some final form you got
the Shiva put an apple on the board
glass of water
yeah names that girl that's Shiva
playing right now if you're asking about
me my name is chasity
Jimmy say that I'll sit up a bit
backwards as you play yeah you got me so
the people out there we said Jimmy is
the cream of the crop he is the best in
the us best in the entire us yes there's
a noob I believe it's getting ready
definitely I think he's gonna have some
new a competition yeah definitely I
think what we're really excited about is
you know obviously Tekken's been around
for 20 years right
Wow 80 years Wow Jimmy's been playing
since he was what twelve ten years old
um well really excited for Tekken Semin
is this new generation of Tekken fans
actually coming into play so it's very
exciting
we've seen some of that into eSports
kind of scene right now and what we
announced yesterday was even more
exciting our Tekken World Tour so oh yes
so the technical tour is our eSports
kind of roll out for this year it is a
global thing so there's actually a
regional kind of leaderboard so it's all
based on points so there's Asia Pacific
compete in one region the Americas and
then Europe and it's all points base so
if you actually win the top five people
each region actually go to the World
Finals to see who's going to be crowned
the king of Iron Fist so a lot of the
kind of EF GC events are rolled into the
schedule so you have evil obviously is
the biggest funding your idolize so the
person that wins that automatically
qualifies for the World Finals Wow
but CEO is where the tour actually kicks
off in Orlando so that is Mitch you so
if you're wanting to get a piece of that
$200,000 kind of prize pool that we're
offering up get good get the game on
June 2nd there you go get good guys
yeah learn to play and get good yeah
learn to play good you can be part of
the world tour who is up next
man you go back in let's go Ben get
revenge
Vince revenge yeah
binge TiVo you did well
Ben check AKA shades is back no no I'll
try and do a Bourdon right right bunch
look that one's most difficult that's
pretty important though I want that who
will he choose Steve time but down both
kick is pretty important like I'm
wondering who Steve's dad is that is a
mystery who is Steve's father the
Mishima Zaibatsu is did a lot of
experiments a long time ago lots with
Steve Fox is blonde yes conspiracy
theories watery Venus the mom who is the
dad but if it's cool someone called
Jerry Springer I need that paternity
test or not we have nine minutes left in
this stream what you're watching right
now if you're just tuning in is mister
naps playing one-handed as Oscar Kazama
versus our very own Ben djenka with
playing at Steve and we'll see who wins
woo
we're also hang out in chat so you have
nine minutes left you ask your questions
on twitch and YouTube right now
Jimmy is just so good fundamentally with
his movements occasion jet he is
untouchable even with one hand it's
pretty amazing I know pop series yep
inside Jimmy's head he's just laughing
right now that's pretty boy I think
someone needs to give Jimmy an L
I think someone knows someone music
toast man said is June coming soon woo
Joon is coming in a week June 2nd 2nd 17
minutes oh oh the character thank you ah
ha we will have more news about that
pretty soon about the two guest
characters that are in the season pass
so we said the are from two other
franchises so great exciting news other
franchise is very exciting hmm
who's Julie Chad we do get a lot of
requests for other characters all to see
that bit in Tekken in the second
universe before and I think for the fans
out there that actually want to get back
in their characters anyway
yeah that's ways to kind of go on social
media
tweet at her Otteson that's Tekken and
request these characters yeah request
the characters that you want
her Otteson he is the main producer on
Tekken as well or throwing it throws and
requests the characters that you want
yes also there's a bonus character if
you preorder is that correct yes so
nobody or the character you get Eliza
so Eliza is this vampire character that
originally appeared in Tekken Revolution
on ps3 nice so if you pewter the game on
any platform you actually get her day
one when you pick up your game so that
includes digitally - very nice so you
get her for free which is awesome
scooter characters yeah yeah I like four
whole vampire setting okay whoops okay
alright alright Richard's up I think
Richards gonna take this I believe in
you you can do this Richard this is
where I break a clipboard and I say do
your best your best isn't good enough
alright there we go go for some sweeps
you can get around whoa
hey oh there we go
Oh keep some distance in there yeah
keep him at a distance you can't move as
well on YouTube said who is a guy given
the ticket seven info this is Mark he is
the brand manager for Tekken 7 correct
yes how long have you been with second I
have been in bed with Tekken for about
two and a half years now it's been a
long journey but it's been amazing
journey as well um you know I've been
working on this ever since we announced
our cave version so I've been excited to
actually see kind of you know what the
fans are saying about the game and and
seeing a lot of old kind of Tekken bands
come out of the woodwork and go like wow
this is Tekken now on ps4 and Xbox and
PC so it's been amazing journey I'm just
happy that fans are finally getting the
game that's yeah yeah also very exciting
that it's coming out on PC yes let's
hear a little bit more about PC so it's
gonna be 60 frames per second you said
60 frames per second and 4k if you're
Rick can actually handle that so we
recently announced the PC specs you can
check that out on our social media
channels alright but it's definitely
exciting for kind of the PC proud to get
Tekken for the first time so yeah that
is very exciting good job Richard
Richard gotta read though keep them he's
gonna sidestep I am no longer special
keep him there though some fireballs and
you can lean on that Tatsu oh there we
go
you know what try some command throws oh
he doesn't we have five minutes left in
the stream I believe in you Richard we
have Richard playing mister naps mister
naps playing one-handed without his
glasses
second row of fun see you touch you
alright
Wow huh two rounds good job red you guys
size up all right blocks hmm captain
where's the perenna back at least
there's wing walls in this stage or safe
here that's true there are no walls row
break teleport whoa oh boy I think this
turn app says this room once you get a
rager oh no all right this is for the
win when we round for the wind I go back
up good teleports even a distance
Jimmy is out for blood here the
continuation oh oh this is tense here
some lows here we go yeah there you go
you're gonna want to read your oh wow
all right Richard got two rounds you
bested me all right I probably lost one
we've got three minutes left so this
might be the very last one yeah yeah
yeah yeah bring it back he's going crazy
all right all right mister naps is still
playing without his glad he was one
handed yeah no you let an earthquake
tickle him now he must be very timid
don't lose your win bring out the French
on that give up the man wanted yeah he
needs us a third handicap Turpin with
the right hand you play at the right
hand like good yeah
well good job here match - all right oh
it's a mirror match mr. Winn
right here you got this man no pressure
all the hope is on you though I believe
in your name spot cheap yeah the game
spot champion who doesn't it don't sound
a mirror match I'm trying I'm trying
really hard
I believe mr. Wynn's in blue is that
correct nice this doesn't count as an
excuse to play with his right hand side
yeah he's still with his left hand got
it yeah naps just at the wall they're
trying to break through that right now
look at all the hopeful there it is
running Q Oh
mr. Natz Surgical here
nice counter good trade let's all say to
help Hail Mary
yeah come on
cool all right mr. Wynn check that you
got this get back up no don't get stuck
in this corner radar freezer Oh you
forget alone ins everybody's pick up and
counter boring your machine apps has a
twin yeah in the combo here with a smile
on his face there's there's the comeback
oh all right well let's bring mr. naps
back to the desk here because he is the
champion of the day no mister when you
are still the gamespot champion even
though you do not work in the office you
are the king of list explorer you are
welcome back anytime we have bagels here
on Fridays oh thank you guys for
watching thanks for joining us thank you
Mark and thank you mister naps thanks
for being us Oh bad I got around yes you
get that - I got a rapid thank you so
much for joining us and Tekken 7 coming
up June 2nd Xbox ps4 and PC check it out
and I'll see you next time guys bye
[Music]
you
[Music]
you